I want to make you a chart
of how tall people were
100 years ago.
Height data tends to be split by gender.
So, we'll look at women
for now.
Okay, we're ready.
We'll chart heights by country.
Let's look at where my dad's family
is from: South Korea.
The average woman born near
the beginning of the 1900s
like my great grandmother
was just 142 centimeters
or 4'7".
For comparison, the average
American woman
was 159 centimeters
or 5'2".
If we chart every country...
we can see that people
a century ago
were pretty short for
today's standards.
But over the next hundred years,
humans grew.
Let's just look at those blue bars:
How much each country grew.
We need to adjust
the vertical axis
so we can see this chart better.
Ah, that's better.
Many of the countries that saw
the most growth
were European, North American
countries.
For example, here's France
and here's the US.
The countries that grew the least
were in Africa.
And Asian countries were
mostly in the middle.
But all the way on the right is an outlier.
A country where women
grew nearly 8 inches
in the last century.
South Korea.
And South Korean boys
grew nearly 6 inches
in that time period.
So why did humans grow
so much in such a short amount of time?
And why did this happen
in South Korea?
For most of the last 2000 years
human height didn't change much.
This chart shows the height
of European men...
but this stagnation pretty much
was happening everywhere.
But in the last 200 years
we started to see
some growth.
Here's some better data of 1800s.
You can see people in wealthier
European countries
starting to get taller.
We know a lot about why.
And it all starts with our genes.
One study from 2006 looked at
thousands of siblings...
and analyzed how much of
their DNA was shared...
and compared that to how different
their height was.
They found that about 80%
of the difference
in sibling height is genetic.
But that other 20%
are external forces that
affect our height.
Because even if our DNA says
we can grow to a certain height
during puberty...
that growth is
often interrupted.
There's a great study that tracks
English and Welsh boys
born in the 1890s.
Many of these boys eventually
enlisted in WWI
which created a record of their adult height.
Researchers compared that
to their childhood living conditions
using the 1901 census.
They found that, if a person grew up
in a white collar household...
which probably had better access to nutrition...
they were on average
about a half inch taller
than everyone else.
If they grew up in a crowded home
where they were more likely
to spread disease or infection...
they were nearly a third
of an inch shorter.
And if they grew up in an industrial area
exposed to pollution and disease
they were nearly an inch shorter.
Even within the same country
the environment had a noticeable effect
on people's height.
That's what changed drastically
in the last 200 years.
Over the last century
we made massive advancements
in nutrition, sanitation
medicine and overall
quality of life.
And humans got way taller.
But now let's put South Korea
on this chart.
100 years ago, South Korea was poor
and the people were shorter
than the global average.
But by the 1960s, they had
mostly caught up.
Then something drastic happened.
A military-led government
focused on economic growth.
Eventually, the country shifted
from producing things like textiles
to consumer electronics and cars.
And South Korean wealth skyrocketed.
In the 60s, many South Koreans
didn't have enough to eat.
The food supply was basically in line
with other low-income countries.
But the food supply
rapidly improved
and soon it exceeded
the world average.
And then it caught up to affluent
countries in Europe.
As for childhood health,
in the 1950s
more than 20% of South Korean kids
died before age one.
Worse than most low income countries.
Then, South Korea's infant mortality
plummeted.
And as a result of these improved conditions...
especially for children, South Koreans kept
growing and growing.
I want to show you
one more chart.
This is the height of South Koreans
and North Koreans in the 1930s.
Back then, they were
one country
so naturally they were
about the same height.
The North is where my
maternal grandparents
and their siblings grew up.
Then in 1945
the North and South were split up.
In 1950, the Korean War began.
The war ended in a stalemate
and North Korea
shut its borders
walling itself off from
the rest of the world.
In the 1990s
millions of North Koreans
starved to death.
We only have data on
North Korean height today
because of the thousands of people
who escaped to the South
during that period.
And in the generations
since the division...
the height gap between the two Koreas...
has continuously widened.
My grandparents were lucky.
Early in the war, they fled
their home in North Korea...
and escaped to the southern tip
of South Korea.
And a few years later,
my mother was born.
My mom is a bit taller
than her mother...
and my generation
is taller than hers.
Height is inherited
written into our very genetic code.
But height is also something...
history gives to us.